At each of Whole Foods Market's
more than 500 American stores,
managers ask every team member,
from the meat clerks to the baristas
to the janitorial staff, to orient their work
around a shared purpose, which is to make natural
and healthy food widely available. This goal, according
to Whole Foods CEO and founder John Mackey,
is in no way inconsistent with maximizing shareholder value.
As Mackey writes in his new book,
"At the heart of conscious capitalism
is a radical refutation of the negative perceptions
of business, and a rejection of the split
between purpose and profit."
At a Soho Forum debate held on February 18th, 2020,
Ayn Rand Institute Chair Yaron Brook challenged this view.
He believes that maximizing profit should always be the
primary goal of companies, and it's that focus, which
explains why capitalism has lifted the broad masses
out of poverty.
That's the message businesses should be emphasizing,
he says, and it's inspiring enough.
Mackey and Brooks went head to head at an event
hosted in front of a sold-out audience of 200 people
at the Brownwood Hotel and Spa in Florida.
John Mackey wasn't able to make it to the event
because of weather conditions in Austin, Texas,
but he appeared via Zoom.
A clearly articulated purpose, consciously embodied
by the leadership, should be an essential element
in all business organizations, while also enhancing
shareholder value.
John I'm going to interrupt you when you have
five minutes to go, one minute to go and 30 seconds
just to warn you, so take it away John, on that resolution.
Go ahead.
Thanks Gene.
I'm going to bring my slides up now.
Okay, great.
So anyway, sorry, I can't be with you.
I tried very hard to get there.
Bad weather. What can I say?
So this debate resolution is a mouthful.
It is, a clearly articulated purpose consciously invited
by the leadership should be an essential element
in all business organizations,
while also enhancing shareholder value.
What the heck does that actually mean?
We couldn't quite get an agreement on the topic
and this was somewhat of a compromise I think,
but essentially the way I interpret it is
that, does business have a higher purpose
besides only maximizing profits?
And yeah, I think it does.
And that's what I'm going to talk about.
So let me declare my bias upfront.
I am a fanatical capitalist.
I believe capitalism is the most important
thing that humanity's collectively ever done.
And I'm going to demonstrate that briefly
because people need to understand how
incredible capitalism is.
Starting with, we can see the increasing wealth that
capitalism has produced.
For most of human history, humans have been incredibly poor.
It wasn't until capitalism and the industrial revolution
that humanity began to escape its poverty conditions.
If you go back, it's unprecedented, just 200 years ago
the world's economy was at the level
of Sierra Leone is today: 94 percent of everyone alive were poor.
Now the per capita income has grown by over 10X,
over 24X in the United States, 41X in Hong Kong,
75X in South Korea.
It's incredible. How about poverty?
Again 94% of everyone alive back in 1820 was living
on less than 2.00 dollars a day in today's dollar. 94 percent.
85 percent lived on less than 1.00 dollar a day.
Economic freedom has a lot to do with whether or not how,
economically prosperous any type of country is.
The more economically free it is the higher
the GDP per capita.
The poorest people, it's better to be poor in a
country like the United States, with economic freedom
than in another poorer country.
So economic freedom also helps the poorest.
Life expectancy has gone from about 30 years,
200 years ago now, to 72.6 across the world
and usually close to 80 in more developed, economically
prosperous countries.
Illiteracy, it's hard to believe, but 200 years ago
88 percent of every human being alive was illiterate.
And that's dropped now down to about 12%.
Here's the economic freedom index, I put this up there
to make a couple of points.
The first one is is the United States
which would have been, has been number one,
number two, or number three for most of our history.
It's fallen, we've fallen.
Economic freedom is in decline in the United States,
and as a result our prosperity, while still very good,
it's not growing at the same rate
that it once did.